foreign
's YouTube channel and today we will
learn how to delete a column and SQL but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies and if you're a tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply turn now without further Ado
let's get started so how do you delete a
column in SQL now let's quickly take a
look on the syntax we will be using
today so we will be using the alter
table keyword then the table name the
dropkeeper to drop a particular column
name and followed by the drop keyword we
have the column name which we are
supposed to be dropping off now that we
have a clear idea about the syntax let's
get back to the MySQL workbench to
execute this particular command so far
we try to create a database create a
table add some data onto the table using
the insert command and update a
particular Tuple and try to eliminate a
single row now we are trying to
eliminate a complete column here so
let's not eliminate the existing columns
let's try to create a new column and
then try to eliminate it so for that we
will be using the alter table command so
this is the alter table command and the
employee table which is the employee
table name then we are trying to use the
add keyword and we are trying to add a
new column that is the PIN code which is
a worker or character data type and not
null we're not keeping it as null and in
case if we did not add any value into
the PIN code the default value will be n
a which is a text type so we are
encoding it using single quotes now
let's try to run this code
and let's quickly try to check the table
um
apply table
and there you go now we have pin code
here and the null values in the PIN code
so we don't want the spin code over here
so we will eliminate this pin code
column using the same alter command so
Alt
table
then the table name
and then the column we want to drop
using the drop keyword which is pin code
so let's execute this command and see
the output
so there you go the PIN code column has
been successfully eliminated so so
that's how you completely eliminate a
column in SQL and with that we have come
to an end of the session on how to
delete a column in SQL if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session then do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here